une maison de hobbit en plein morvan
d'après cette carte nous serions tout
près du but
je vous propose de poursuivre notre
recherche
à
bonjour stéphane bourgeois yannick nous
avait enfin trouvé ça y est on a trouvé
votre maison de hobbit
venez on va vous faire visiter avec gehl
bonjour gaël bonjour stéphane bienvenue
de m merci alors une maison de hobbits
c'est quoi alors une maison de 8 en fait
c'est l'idée et images du film le
seigneur des anneaux tiré du livre de
tolkien est en fait c'est une maison
sous terre tout petit
habité par des lutins à pieds poilus
on a essayé de faire une maison qui
ressemblait un petit peu à l'esprit du
film et du livre
et puis on a surtout ici un beau terrain
de jeu qui correspond à l'esprit aussi
du film s'attire le morvan avec les
terrains légendaire le lac est juste à
20 mètres des arbres magnifiques et donc
on s'est dit ça va vraiment encore lié
avec le génie du lieu
ici vous avez la chambre parentale avec
un petit guide au but mais tout le monde
peut rentrer dedans quand même vous avez
également ici à la baignoire
en fait c'est une belle manche de
viticulteurs qu'on va perméabilité avec
de la résine et on va faire tout un
petit côté ce pas parce qu'on trouvait
que ça faisait moyen-âgeux et que ça
correspondait à l'esprit du film n'a pas
de magasin deux buts encore qui existent
donc en fait on a dû aller chiner dans
les vide greniers venu dans les emmaüs
se chercher dans leboncoin pour trouver
des meubles vraiment qui dit mac à
ressembler à peu aux décors du film
au final on a réussi quand même à
trouver un bel ensemble donc ici vous
avez le salon un fauteuil convertibles
une place qui date des années 30 donc
c'est un des premiers canapé convertible
et là un canapé convertible des années
vous pouvez loger deux enfants et faire
dormir le troisième ici donc ici on est
dans la pièce la plus importante pour
les obliques la salle à manger parce que
les hobbits il adore manger
et donc voilà on est resté dans
l'atmosphère du film si par exemple
c'est exactement la même arme marque
dans le film et la grande tablée pour
les soirées un petit peu olé olé des
hobbits
on est sur la maison de hobbits elles
toutes recouvertes de terre et de gazon
parce qu'on à semer du gazon des fleurs
ci est donc cette maison elle et ça
permet à deux ans et a pas de filtration
il ya une bâche et par dessus donc être
la terre végétale
c'est un projet un peu écolo et que ça
ouais voilà c'est aussi divisés
voilà c'est ça dans l'idée un peu et
surtout qu'on est près du lac de
chamboux un réservoir pour l'eau potable
justement on veut vraiment préserver ces
domaines alors c'est marrant parce que
cette maison de l'it qui on dirait une
nicoline parmi les collines du morvan
oui ah oui elle est belle se fond
totalement dans le morvan quoi le moment
c'est vrai que c'est très vallonné on
dirait qu a toujours été là
le résultat vraiment il est là c'est le
sourire des gens le bonheur quand il
voit les petits décors les petits
dragons dans les murs
il ya plein de détails qu'on est content
parce que les gens les voient ah bah
tiens justement qu'est ce que c'est que
cet anneau